your queen where's the Queen going
protective suit is devastating it's
overworked Luke takes f7 is the next
move oh no ouch town population pork
neck Queen e6
just play 2600 eat no Queen d8 prevents
the wind takes up seven wow what a pin
we had a nice fine yeah girl reduce it
he puts the Queen on c5 look for Brooke
takes f7 followed by Bishop takes d5
discover its discovery ting discoveries
we just discovered some discoveries oh
man OMGs or snaps
[Music]
and to all nearly 5,500 of you with us
whether you're a twitch.tv slash chess
chess comm TV thank you for being here
the bullet chess championship rolls on
as we are getting set for the finals to
take place between grandmaster Sakura
Nakamura and olexander bortnik and in
order to preview that match we we did
some homework today and and douve go
behind the scenes I think a big question
for everybody Robert is what does
Bortnick got to do to have a chance
against akaru and will some of and if he
does those things will some of those
things actually maybe be a little
menacing to Hikaru on that note we
actually did a little research and said
as we would in any matchup what's the
history between these two guys and I
have something that might surprise the
fans do you want to lead the way and
take us through this game I'm a little
scared to Danny because it hurts me it
pains me to see this because if you look
through the first couple moves of the
game right you see the e4 g6 typical
modern defense setup right
d4 Bishop g7 still we're in typical
opening Theory picture of h6 and by
bortnik that's where you grab your head
in your life that's probably that must
be the signal besides Queen h5 right
single worst move on the board is Bishop
h6 I can't think of a worse made Bishop
major it's similarly bad but Bishop h6
and it's like oh no you didn't oh no you
did but of course you're anticipating
the pre move so after a6 he took on g7
and that's what any card Nakamura says I
hate you we're never playing again I
guess what happened after that game fans
they have not played since in this game
where bortnik pulled the lafawn and beat
hit karo with the with the replay
instant replay gonna let the moves play
out on the board hey Cara Nakamura
resigned this position naturally and
refused to continue playing a bullet
match that had been going against
bortnik and so from the from on the one
hand you totally understand right this
like it's super frustrating especially
for grandmaster that level be like come
on dude but it's also an indicator of of
some of the things that make bullet
chess unique right you you are always
trying to take advantage of your
opponent's pre moves and anticipate
opportunities to catch them in a swindle
that is unique to a time scramble unique
to people pre moving in playing bullet
chess and on
no we have she saw that yesterday Robert
so we bring up the next game here
between Alexander Grichuk and Morton
again in a match that again
I had Grichuk winning this match and I I
thought that he was the better player
and I think he was but you got to give
bortnik credit for having the skill of
knowing when those opportunities are
there in this position the most natural
next move to play given the Grichuk had
just played a seven is of course to get
a queen but bortnik had already set up a
scenario where his King was stalemated
and so he played the move Bishop to b8
of course any other moves winning for
grish look like no debate right g7 gets
his matin - followed by a lady on g8
right of course taking is checkmate in
one but one move had already been pre
moved and likely on Otto Queen of course
the move a a queen and bortnik once
again had swindled his way to a victory
and bull chest so let me ask you this
before we move on from this point we've
now seen him completely pulled the
lafawn and and really upset Hikaru -
playing an absolute you know nasty no
excuse for this sort of behavior frowned
upon in all 50 states this sort of move
Bishop to b8
but is there a skill there to anticipate
those opportunities that bortnik has
there absolutely is Danny and you know
this is the kind of most clear-cut
example because it ends the game on the
spot but much more frequently you see
opponent take upon when you know that
someone just shuffling their pieces back
and forth they'll take a pawn that's
actually not on pretty so the opponent
gets captured back but they don't have
the time - we saw Ali Riza firoozeh do
that where let's say there's a I'm just
trying to think of even it let's say the
book a 8 equals Queen wasn't played so
you miss it should the b8 knowing some
other move was pre moved so your next
move can be Bishop takes pawn and you're
like it's very frequent that you see
situations like this occur it is a skill
and okay this is like the most you know
blatant example of a terrible pre move
gone wrong but it happens much more
frequently that people may think when
it's a normal-looking position but both
sides have six seconds left so you put
your rook attacking the other person's
rook where they could take you for free
but they've already pre moved some other
move and then you go and take their work
right so it is a skill you need to time
it correctly sometimes you just get
fortunate and other times it backfires
so it's you know you make your own luck
they say but I think brennick then
great job emphasizing why this is a part
of bullet chess but of course
on that note bortnik is not just a
Windler right he also is a very strong
chess player and he's gonna need both if
he has any chance against the Cara
Nakamura and on that note we wanted to
pull up a game here that he had
yesterday where this may have been the
final nail in MV else coffin board Nick
despite being under pressure as black
here and MBL's trying to launch an
attack that that might get frisky here
if you give him another move the Knights
coming to h6 everybody so if you make
some sort of random move this move hits
f7 a double attack by the bishop and the
knight and if you take it max seems
attack immediately becomes very very
dangerous but bortnik pausing
appropriately it calculates very very
well Bishop takes f5 and then nine h4
and suddenly you and I or I actually
think Eric was with me then we were both
just sort of surprised like oh wait yeah
actually the Queen has to retreat black
is gonna win that pawn on f5 and then he
went on to just simply just just crush
Maxime in this game the knight came to
d5 and after g6 and then the trick with
e4 very very quickly spotting the
potential dynamics of a fork and indeed
that emote went viral in the chat and
you had pieces falling and bortnik went
on to win a game really with absolutely
no real no real difficulties here and
this game I think in many ways was the
final final chance there would there
would be no more come back after bortnik
crush Maxime here and delivered may
don't have to so so again there's the
swindles we've seen it we've seen the
last game you played against a car but
there's also some high-quality chess and
one more one more example of that we
actually did our research and and found
this video where Alexander bortnikov his
own even against the world champion
Magnus Carlsen that we're gonna take a
quick peek on it's the final time this
game has somewhat less time and still
his roof is well stable team struggles
to find an open file still struggles to
find an open file with his red while his
opponent seems to play with
with Akane for NFC it's a very annoying
double attack I'm sure Magnus has
blunted this one
I don't think a fake
now he's something he's there he's down
night for three parts yeah it's three
points for those poles you know they are
not connected postponed so objectively
White's position is much by the Queen
III Queen d4 he might still save this
one but it's a very very bad position
now King to g7 55 room to c8
a check on second rank yeah that's good
checks checks all the time now rugby one
magnet detectors show the portal why to
hide the king yes for next up a night
here for two pawns but at the same game
it's only White's came to win drawing
Magnus this is totally different than
the bullet we're about to see with that
two second increment makes it feel like
this is lasting forever
people are like take the time away what
is kind of like once you have skittles
you're like you don't give me like some
sort of like candy that has any sort of
health benefits right yeah like this
increment it's like take it away from me
right it's just like prolonging the game
here which is you know all right better
moves for sure and ultimately I think
they're gonna repeat right here and all
right all right we'll let it play out
here keep waiting for the game to end in
a draw for next showing that he doesn't
really have any friends
that's Magnus keeps preventing this with
those two commentators look at real
stoic the opposite of me and you yeah
we're the hasn't
vote can't be bored if you sit still I
try my best but when I don't succeed you
try again
hashtag alia as you say you get what you
want and what you need that's true and
when I feel tired I can't sleep are we
doing this right now I want you to try
to fix me I'll fix you Chris Martin as
soon as you fix your relationship status
when I go to e5 was 95 he just went d4
it's a 95 a couple I mean maybe I want a
little delay here but I think the Brooke
still had five check from b5 now the
King has to go back nothing to it so at
least we know that while he may rely on
a lot of pre boost windows he does he
does also try to win endgame sometimes
that be important we are five minutes
away from the bullet Chess Championship
final everybody fine and there you go
Magnus finally he's gonna pick up the
Jeep owner force Knight f3 here dd-does
time to get my hair cut Diane that can't
wait for this match tonight I'm excited
yeah one last trick there by bortnik if
you take g5 there was 96 check on the
four fork Nick fork Nick to fork night
no I I do love your board next wrong
thing but it's really funny hey bored
Nick is stronger Oh F six trading off
that last pawn
dangerous but he's a party
look at him living off the increment oh
you see some of that blitz kill a slash
bullets kill really coming out Wow but
uh but now he's recovered there he was
down to a couple seconds increments
brought him back her co-commentator
money I'm getting a little bit of a
break here off-camera we don't know you
more happy about that so I'm gonna let
it right out Yeah right off into the
sunset my friend be like Jared Allen
when he retired well by the way did
anyone in the chat watch the final four
game yesterday no you gave me a break to
talk about basketball
open the door you open the door
we got GM John Davis love in Texas we
got some UVA baby
hey UVA got pretty fortunate can't deny
that a double dribble that everybody
should have noted there there you go oh
and we have our players here just like
that all right
we've got one of them on camera hey Cara
Nakamura we've got bortnik still rocking
the Armenian nightclub look well we'll
check on the status of that but either
way the bullet chess challenge of
getting under way so that was a lot of
fun right we've set the tone obviously I
think that hey Cara Nakamura is
reputation and success kind of speaks
for itself and we know that he is indeed
the heavy favorite in this match as as
it should be considered it'll be it'll
be interesting to see what happens in
the in the new format with the sets
situation in terms of whether that helps
the underdog being bored Nick or
ultimately makes no difference as we saw
max team Bosh a lagravis a vert against
Levon Aronian and do exactly what he was
supposed to do I'm gonna be honest with
you Danny
yep I don't think there is any helping
the underdog in this case when he carved
knock Awards the favorite you have no
chance either he beats himself or he's
just gonna beat you
like hey do we do get a remind hit car
ooh as daryl morey about his last game
against bortnik the one the one that
caused him to stop playing against him
if a car wins the match we're gonna
remind him of that for sure right if he
if he if he somehow does as you said
beat himself and lose this one I don't
know that that's gonna be a topic that
we broach but we'll see how the players
are engaging with us after the show of
course everybody stick around there are
6,500 of you with us as there should
because guess what the hype is real the
bullet Chess Championship finals is
about to get underway it's all led us to
this as we said two completely different
paths here by these guys to get in this
spot one player being seated as the 1
seed the unofficial best player in the
world at bullet may be about to make
that official the other guy played in
every single event we've had since April
3rd to this moment and now he's got the
hardest task of all to play a car
Nakamura to match and in about 60
seconds here the match will get underway
give us your hype give us your love give
us that hesse chasm new emote Roberts
gonna be cutting his hair and shaving
his face after this match so this is
your last chance to see what to see what
you got on hick on camera here it's the
last chance true it's a hundred percent
true this beard is going away this hair
is being cut cannot wait for it so give
everybody everybody get high because I'm
high and we see Zbornak on camera here
he just got this webcam because he
didn't have one honestly it's a pretty
good camera oh it looks like a great
camera also looks like nice choice with
the curtains there I like the style the
drapes seemed to match probably the
carpet I don't know what's going on on
the floor but we'll see and we've got
we've got bortnik sitting down and ready
to rock you ready I'm ready I'm ready to
about to get underway here we go ready
legs let's go I'm so pumped Danny I'm so
excited how many games we win a set it's
six games like tennis all right we got
III by Hikaru he just that's how you
start things off and again remember
everybody this is a format that is
broken up into chunks we have a
best-of-five so it takes three sets to
win winning a game gets you a game point
six points are required to win the set
and set has to be won by two games or
more
ready to slow Danny 7 seconds ahead it's
a car right now black is doing quite
solidly right now or looks worse if he
moves the night before play tonight
before trying to get c5 and ok 98 same
idea in 96 play for c5 and so board
done well his position looked
worse the cold moves ago he's gotten rid
of his backwards pawn but right now it's
all hay car on the clock I haven't go
Knight e4 Knight g5 some point I want to
take that Bishop on after he this move
looks like it just loses a pawn now if
you take that pawn can't take back his
rook to d1 pins the bishop so he's
thinking but you know he's spending too
much time here in a car this is a story
line we highlighted yesterday that
important ink did consistently get down
on the clock against people but found
has found his swindle game when it
mattered most the issue is can you have
a swindle game against a car oh right 97
coming yeah I don't think you can but
look this Bishop on c3 very strong piece
here very strong
nice position yep and look at this D
pawn now so instead it black has a
double F pawns isolated you look a rock
h3 nice move by a car or swing his rook
it's activity but that was a nice fine
rook g58 f4 okay you weren't very nice
buy a car now he'll gobble up the H pawn
as soon as he's into it first you put
this on I don't know five here comes
rook takes h5 oh no he wants to prevent
roachie too even better J here comes the
rook anyway probably not enough for
bortnik to do anything but lose on time
here though I mean this it Wow I'll be
about to see a 30 second yeah we are and
that I have words for that he's so fast
that's a time that's a time dominance
that is worth like I mean I don't want I
hate those math conversions you know me
Robert I'm not a guy who even like
saying things like the bishop hair is
worth you know seven points or I don't
like those because I don't believe the
director of comparisons are fair but a
30-second time advantage is worth
practically a rook yeah I mean that's
insanity
that's insanity what was Queen h2 there
I don't know what it is he's not just
for full bullet mode with bortnik but
yeah this is weird
Oh busy 6q hey Carl shakes his head he's
unhappy for missing that one but finds
Knight g5 there's no made on h7 very
nice whoa take me a tour though so when
he's in part actually a blender me don't
have to be too so take you gotta be
careful with this night we got a battery
pokin here here come's
for at some moment and Hikaru wants the
battery he trees falling with check he
didn't take it I don't know why I didn't
take it yeah it was messed that up so
beat you don't wanna go b3 that opens of
the diagonals the king bee oh he does it
oh ho a car was not gonna let him take
that one back right goats rook t3 King D
- it's safe 94 in it Oh watch out route
63 is for us but the Queen will come in
anyway yep Hikaru does it Oh cat five f5
f5 was winning a piece there they both
missed in fact white Ricardo and bortnik
both missing the move f5 which would
have fork the Queen and night everybody
so whites better here up a pawn to f7
pawn is weak Queen in d5 he's taking
some of this position why it's also
better creates quite a few Quidditch
when it's gonna be mate oh hey Carl gets
out barely taken any five he won upon
though and now this is Queen Elizabeth
Zbornak does his best work though
everybody despite being down on the
clock this is this is in swindle
territory we'll see if board they can do
it I don't think he can too much time
and Sushant enough time in fact as soon
as the car will eliminate the Knights
I'm gonna call it there will no be be no
swindle
that's what Hikaru is going to avoid all
day if he wins this match Wow look at
the pre move skill there that was the
that was Opie stuff as the kids say
shout out to all the kids or adults in
twitch chat or chest comm TV because
Hikaru oh P stands for over pomegranate
berries what I thought Opie was original
poster original poster I thought it was
over pomegranate when I go to Jamba
Juice I order opium over pomegranate I'm
what Barry's got it that's fair and are
you over the dark squares as well
because blacks taken all I've bet I've
been over the dark squares for a long
time buddy the button car is not over
the exchange loss we'll only finds fruit
takes a seven does that hold no but that
was still super trapped
if you an f4 g3 stuff like that now
who's better he chloro blunders the
exchange and he's still better yeah he's
better in the same well that would be
one would be eight he wins that b6 pawn
but okay this is he can't lose this
endgame
no I can in the time situation is gonna
be a huge factor you can display f4 and
g3 put a bishop on the light squares
Bishop g4 check I know I thought there
were able to be like a mate if you trap
the King on a light score at the light
square Bishop take it and go right
before
d7 Bishop e8 the card was gonna hold on
and maybe he'll just take h5 it yeah he
settles this is borning declined to draw
and now okay he came to agree to that
draw whoo yeah a car making the polite
decision there I think because he could
have probably played for time given that
he was up seven seconds no respect
sporting speed enough to know that board
I could have held it anyway and I was
gonna say it's also very dangerous
because the rook is probably the much
easier thing to pre move in that in that
dynamic right yeah absolutely
I like what boardings thrown in this
game because he's made sure that there
no breaks for black and so you can't go
seasick to the night hanging on b6 so if
your car you can you move that night and
then try for c6 but look at Bishop g2
coming then see f3 although that c7 pawn
Danny route 95 rook c1 I love it take on
c5 here just ok you gotta defend v3 if
Knight takes d5 you're gonna punch e4
through he does it yep you're coming to
the bishop poking at the rook on a1 and
that was a big blunder by morning he's
blundering right now but look is he's
got a counter here Castle key tonight
for nine every wing g6 - if you want it
at some point a1 is hanging okay so he's
won back some material plus the nice
those nice move forcing the kings of the
board look at bortnik speeding up he
knows his only real chance is to make
sure he's not under that cut you can't
he can't do what he was doing to some of
his other opponents hey car was just too
fast in the scramble yeah and his look
he's losing this one but the Knights are
tricky night a fourth hits Age 5 you had
trade rooks now very smart get the rooks
off the board if you're her car oh now
you can work on the the past see pawn
I'm gonna put the bishop on d3 who I
thought he would okay then takes a 4
nice move that's gonna be harsh hard to
recover I can't take because you win
with the pin man he cars Wallace
execution Shao Khan just came out and
went flawless victory and Zbornak shook
his head just like he's like he's like
I'm not worthy I'm not worth wow wow
that was just Hikaru going full puzzle
rush mode that was nuts man
man all right so here we go so we see a
car taking a typical so easy for him to
play quick moves and this is sort of
like what his last round game against
Jeffrey Zhong was we're here there's
some ideas where they can playing c5 I
can opposing f5 in that game which black
actually wants to get a little bit my
activity but I listen to his twitch
commentary about that game and was
really fascinating to hear his thoughts
and hear what the white piece is Danny
he's going after the e7 Polly's taking
over the dark squares I play h4 h5 and
try to get h6 in so this becomes a
position that is so hard to be borgnik
because hey karo already up on the clock
is also in a position where the moves
are easier for white the queen is
centralized you can poke at pawns even
if there's no concrete fret that's a
weak and now you better watch out for
the cheap pawn epon and G pawn I got two
of them to target a queen nice it was a
nice defensive move there play Brooke a6
to d6 alright I thought you should have
okay he's gonna tuck the king we take
but just queen she forward to enough on
rookie oh I thought Ricky four was
coming and it may come now but he's
fighting it oh it's a queen d1 but the
two pieces come on it the Queen's
trapped they all you have to trade oh
what's more he wants taro hungry works
he said he would wait at right now the
who he's gonna trade and the b2 Brooke
is a prisoner to the b3 pawn rook c3 the
flipping technique the flipping
technique I can't even take it
he's so good god I couldn't find rook c3
with an hour on the clock it's a slight
exaggeration but as different schemes
biggest disappointment I'm just looking
at that guy below me and you know glad
I'm not facing him right now it's okay
you're you're but here with black pieces
a card in his typical setup he's got
some weaknesses the d6 pawn in
particular but g4 is to weakening for
white girl opening up here your king
side so instead we get a closed position
where Knights tend to be better than
bishops right the bish 1b 3 goes a fork
said no diagonal to work with the nice
come the a5 in the c-4
telling you white is not gonna be happy
in this game yep
whoa oh how did he get there he's always
watching waiting judging knowing him and
my why
the only two that give me real stress
dreams well oh my gosh f5 the the the
car oh the hikaru fear is real and my
body like that just proved it if I was
wearing a heart monitor you would be
like he's not faking he's not that good
of an actor anxiety car does that's
people it's not just you look at that
move see for though by bortnik he is he
is for the first time I think truly
equal on the clock in a position after
64 67 what a setup very nice when always
actually change anyway that was smart
friends very smart by a car he can hold
with f6 bring the King up on the light
squares and look at the clock situation
extra fit again it's a much easier
position to play for Hikaru his
instincts are just unreal yep but he
gave up hit unfortunate deep on he
didn't have to but even a pre move game
the pre move game is o P dog over
pomegranate is that your o P is that
your meaning on its on point or is it
overpowered dude you're really a dad I
have no idea take it three take that
pawn
how about overused puns in my case
that's right he found it he fell gay he
finds a way to get out of it Hikaru
expresses a small amount of emotion
there biting his lower lip there goes
the ambulance student next chances what
do you think it's still going so slowly
ambulance quicker does not a pro at the
time advantage if a carro started out
slightly off yesterday against Perugia I
feel like today he is slightly on right
knee too nice
yeah but c7 falls in the end it's NBD in
the end it doesn't even matter Danny
right becomes we wait some upon yep he
got c7 and only Hikaru can win again
right but don't you agree it's like
yesterday the match with firoozeh being
closed almost woke him up he destroyed
Aronian and and right now it's hard to
imagine anything but that because Hikaru
is just rude monster we're good to
the car is uh I think a little irritated
with how that got away from him agreed
yep everything to the to our drawing
game now I'm offering the drawings
interesting I guess see just trying to
beat him over the board at this point
hey car was trying to make make sure
bortnik doesn't get a single victory
here right now in the first set anyway
alright so plane quickly board X
nobody's met up he really has he sped up
you got to give him credit for that he
also hasn't moved in the last 20 minutes
somebody somebody poked him okay I guess
I can see the eyes moving quickly
I see the calculation happening yeah
alright so whoa he's act that's smart we
talked that with LaVon that one game
against Maxime shacking up with the King
side attack makes your opponent use a
lot of time but a cars still playing
quickly oh whoa Oh
blunder z6 that might be the first big
mistake we've seen him combine go e5
just push the five it's just lights out
now it's maybe oh we should have done it
still if everything's hanging in carloon
so the girl can't defend anyway but I'm
not sure that was converted in the most
accurate way and there will be no goose
egg at least not in this first set
bortnik finally gets on the board with a
big big win there
yeah and Zbornak shows that he's not
gonna go down without a fight in fact
he's had some decent positions as far
yep of course hit cars and out playing
him that's what a car does to you but
Zbornak has shown some real class here
and he's he's proving why he was only
disturbing enmity to the qualifier round
robin then he made it to the finals here
he's showing his might and he beat
Mexican Russian lagarith he has nothing
to hold it
hang his head about here and I see Brad
Pitt from Fight Club using the oh boy
because I ever started here watch
everything it's a key for East six Queen
h6 mate do it honestly 46 and his Queen
h6 it works it works gonna go for it
wait Carl just did I know he's torturing
him on the dark squares but watch for
this punch through as Roberts been
highlighting at some point now he's the
Oh he allowed it you had to play you had
to put the bishop or play e6 there if
you were abort Nick that diagonal is
gonna come back to haunt you in the
worst way yep here goes you should never
take this 83 pawn because the car will
flip
script on the h8 square this is just in
even Bishop f6 here or Bishop c5 very
nice yeah we're okay seven I was gonna
say you can trade off rooks because the
endgame is winning for white but the
extra pawns over there and technique is
so P the time advantage is Opie Hikaru
Nakamura is completely on point right
now yes is awesome
yep this is gonna go for a net that
makes makes black have nightmares you
flip the rook to this side of the board
which force rookie rook here to see six
but it but that's not the ideal position
and rook d7 to win the bishops board
Nick I can't believe it either brother I
get it shakes his head like what just
happened there amazing shout out to all
70 100 of you with us if you happen to
be tuning into the chest channel for the
first time this is the bullet Chess
Championship on Sunday we have had a
full week of qualifiers amazing games
amazing matches and but this is it this
is the final match shekhar naka more
important at competing for the title of
bullet chess champion here so give us a
follow before you go anywhere else the
biggest events in chess happened right
here appreciate all the subs all the
bits all the love we've been given all
week robert it's been real I felt it and
thank you for everybody thank you to
everybody who's here yeah and look at
this massive Queen side for white our
least it looked like a great Queen side
but all of a sudden the card closes it
and says you're a for pawn is for g4 no
way this just opens up these government
for f6 but Hikaru is Ricardo is
calculating like a stone-cold killer
he's like I don't even care about f6
honeybadger chess odd who's gonna get me
who's gonna get made he wins the bishop
on c4 he made something wrong just hurts
that might be the first set coming to a
close he he wipes the tears from his
eyes whoa whoa 22 and Jesus snaps omg's
or snaps and 20 of you can now use that
emote OMGs or stems chest pay we love
you thank you so much and Hikaru
Nakamura Oh My Jesus naps
wins the first set it's in the books
Hikaru shows that format being new this
is tennis
this is test this is whatever it is
tests or tennis he is he is ready to
rock and the next set is already
underway
the players are are rolling through and
we have twenty gifted subs again thank
you so much chess Bay get those OMGs or
snaps emotes out if you're a new sub
show show us the hype that's how you
think somebody gave you a gifted sub you
spam the chat with emotes ruthlessly for
the rest of the show
hey Dan you have a question yep does
this make you a chandus cuz you're no
okay I got an old tennis I got an old
tennis injury coming back to get me
though I got an old I got old tennis
elbow oh no I guess not share this elbow
here on this table here
I think hey car is giving boarding the
people's elbow ignorin was given giving
everybody fits shout out to swindle
sticks for your twitch prime sub we
appreciate your Prime we accept prime
man hey karo is under the attack but
he's also of a piece he sits up in his
chair we haven't seen a car a shift like
that since 1987 when he joined this
world look at you having his birth year
just in the in your head and also his
birth year and his birthday what am I in
97 man right December 9th that's right
very good let's go and I give you the
reaction 3 watch out for it Carlos says
I got you I got you Dan I'm watching but
he gives up the draw the second time
around yeah yeah is that I don't think a
car wanted the draw no and boardings
gonna take it yeah and a better start
here for Zbornak yeah ok well the second
set is underway remember everybody of
the format today let me remind you that
every set refreshes the score back to 0
and draws count for nothing we have
eliminated the draw from chest hashtag
you're welcome world did you watch the
2018 World Chess Championship and ask
Robert and Danny for a solution and what
did we give you we eliminated draws from
the game by taking it out of the
channeis format yeah yeah it's a you
know it's you said it's a this court
nothing happens to score it just gives
the players a clean slate so 0-0 in this
second set here and if you had a compare
these players to tennis players who
would you compare them to whose board
Nakamura is definitely Djokovic a bad
boy a badass if I can say that he's a
bad boy he's a badass and he and he's
and he's very polarizing people love
Hikaru and then some people don't like
him but you know what that's oh wow
important - gotta win there if I didn't
player bortnik bortnik I don't know is
he like he's me he's Ukrainian right
yeah so I don't even know maybe
oleksandr dog Apple off that's way too
because his name just put a bunch of
continents continents together and let
it roll out of your mouth you take it
back that's not a minute word Bob was
really good like there just I mean I
like tennis a lot so and you don't get
me sorry about this - anyway back to the
chest yeah or like sønderborg nick is up
a game here and we brakes in the center
very quickly and this is good for black
III ponens a weakness Black's King is
safer despite the dark square is being a
bit vulnerable there and okay rook c7
comes in quickly here Queen where's the
Queen going routine f7 is devastating
it's over work with James f7 is the next
move oh ouch town population bortnik
Queen e6 just play Queenie 600 no Queen
d8 prevents the win takes f7
wow what a pin who had a nice fine Jager
over news it he puts the Queen on c5
look for Brooke takes f7 followed by
Bishop takes d5 discover rating
discoveries we just discovered some
discoveries oh man oMG Zoar snaps oh man
Bishop takes d5 checks still good maybe
but it's also got a whole lot of time on
the clock here and it's sick board Nick
shakes his head how could you find that
with only a few seconds that's on me you
know but he does it all the time so
frustrating what you supposed to do
board Nick did win the first game in the
second set proving our format as a
reason why we separated because the
format always allows that at the very
least you will always have a chance to
come back and so bortnik has a clean
slate despite being down one nothing in
the set but okay now it's just even
boardings got to just keep himself under
control he's sacking I know
gonna sack town in this game night takes
g6 rookie six here six per kick c6 b7
work here we've run out of beef because
the bishop on b3 is a prisoner to d5
that's the job you need more pieces it's
not gonna work it's not gonna work
haven't you oh we just saw the akar a
bobblehead for the first time in today
who's feeling good in that chair with
the red while the car was feeling good
in that chair with the red wall look at
that bobblehead good so let's see Mookie
six comes six Knight to d7 can I would
take d5 I'm trying to sacrifice my
knight somewhere he goes 90 to me he's
gonna play C free and bring the bishop
to c2 though that's his only chance to
get more pieces in the game yeah c3 here
okay okay guards not gonna allow it
rookie four he's gained in Tempe like
crazy or 9606 you can't do that there's
no way that yeah a car doesn't agree
either I'm with you buddy
let's do it at the same time yeah maybe
the heck ROH three square bobbleheads
coming out Hikaru should get all of his
victims a bobblehead of him for
Christmas if he has a heart that's what
he'll do bobblehead bobblehead Hikaru
for Christmas for everybody he beaten
the bullet chess championship let's just
mean I'm sure his I'm sure his uh his
his elf would do that Hickey the elf you
know yeah where is he his cousin from
the North Pole would probably get that
for everybody get a bobblehead oh good
he's sooo good okay let's see Zbornak
can hold this one Bishop a3 taken over
all the dark squares and see for
breaking the center and C file opens for
the room to see one okay Bishop II who I
like that decision or Nick
alright it's so creepy it's so creepy
it's not even funny what we do here
right all right we've got the bishop
coming to d4 at some point the battery
is real g7 is a target board make it
removes the Queen but wait there's more
67 he's just winning a pond okay but
look at the Queen coming in that Bishop
needs to remove say if you could just
give up this pawn right yeah the chest
I'll calm bugs prevent you from taking
it off the board and here comes the
counter-attack but it's too slow I don't
think he has enough the a Paul is
running too fast
yep it's the little a pawn that could
and I don't see any sort of counter here
for look at that rook b1 bring
new pieces to the fund the b8 square has
been spied it is accounted for and it is
real right a one girl followed by
another Britney did it again
oops she did it again on b8 I'm not a
girl
that peshkov wasn't it wasn't a girl but
not yet a woman and you didn't need to
become one apparently you know because
the game was over I preach to the next
layer because all I need is time but I
don't know those Britney Spears songs
too well so we'll get a fact check on
that we'll get a fact check on Britney
Spears what's this pawn structure I
missed the entire opening thinking about
Britney Spears song and driving on f7
cars move slightly you could tell he
missed it
yep there's made on da so he had the
piece couldn't be taken everybody
because of rook da that was the tactic
and here cut down goes e5 and once that
goes rookie seven and yeah he resigns
wow Bortnick showing some some fight yep
he does that's the first time he's he's
gotten two games in any said he lost the
first set six to one keeping track I was
there but drawers you know yeah the
drawers don't count right so what do
they go okay hey car whoa whoa Bishop c4
is coming and these light squares are a
problem yeah beauty queen six the double
attacker then I go z6 oh yeah but even
if the Queen falls it's still a problem
so not good way to solve it
very nice by Bortnick you should look at
five trying to trade the rooks and that
square to fix that fixes the structure
you have 70 actually impressive
defensive technique here by bortnik he's
still worse if I can get d5 and Hicks oh
yeah Brooke g7 is coming and with it
with it the cookie crumbles yeah the
cheap on it came over up to you a little
lost over g7 rec h8 moms or uncle on
beyond g8 oh no wow he's good for two is
the car oh guy yeah the Internet is here
to stay
forever he's all right he's all right
I've seen worse players
okay this sacrifice again it didn't work
out the first time for bortnik but he's
going for it again he just need to play
quickly play with that quick attack I
don't know what this Queen is doing over
there on h2 didn't seem useful Knight d5
comes the tempo in the near future I
like 95 instead of 903 but okay
shout-out to diamond members signal dog
who says he doesn't want to blow out
because he loves the chess and loves the
commentary so if you're not rooting for
bortnik you're in the wrong corner Thank
You diamond member single dog
we love you thanks for being here in the
chest TV chat single dog signal dogs say
what awaited single day at the fonts
weirds iggle day okay my bad well I was
wishing you my mistake never gonna
happen again
I want to start a chat I want to sort of
chess school from good enough to he
shakes his head a car was like I'm not
even happy with your play right now yeah
well me and a car are looking in to
start a chess school for kids who can't
read good I have trouble making out the
blue on the thing thank you to Diamond
member fix this as well any hooters
thanks to everybody oh this is tough to
watch he's so good you're so good you
know why it's tough to watch because you
played a card bullet before right
yep it's know what it feels like yep
you're like I've had a good position and
I'm down 27 seconds the car now there's
the positions not good but we just been
there oh man oh man we feel for you
mister Bortnick we feel for you you know
doesn't feel right now though hey Carly
is a stone-cold robot killer a
sophisticated chess robot sent back
through time to change the future for
one lucky chess website that's Jeff's
calm you really strung it together on
the fly because I have to tell you
struggling and yeah that's what I kept
it going I have this ability to think of
the next word I'm gonna say while I'm
saying this word like yes which next
word I'm gonna say mango didn't see that
coming did ya I'm just calling you juni
Cortez
efore d5 it's happening it's real item 9
exists he just wins a piece three get a
bad but Knight takes a course he's
everything and she
his head with it because he keeps free
don't do you want to take with the
bishop yeah he just doesn't lose
anything
yeah he's ridiculous he's too good I
think we're gonna have a small break
after this one before we move on to the
third and final set assuming it is the
final set at this point but a car Oh
shame on you for being so good Queen g5
had an f3 check idea so you know you
could one four tricks or sometimes you
just got to go for tricks when you're in
trouble and I have six and he shakes his
head he gives us the duck lips number
thirteen I'm not even happy with this
I'm gonna take a quick break because I
got to enjoy myself and you're not gonna
go anywhere I'm watching all seventy six
hundred and four of you I can see you
through the camera if you don't believe
it why does Zuckerberg have the tape on
his laptop okay I can see you I'm
watching you you're not allowed to get
up these guys can take a break you won't
but we will be right back with more
bullet shows championship in just a
moment
I think they rematched each other they
are so anxious to get back at it they
started before we told them to go but
hey that's cool
let's do it welcome to the bullet chess
championship all of you thank you for
being here at car Nakamura currently
leads two sets to nil but there's always
a chance for a comeback in the tennis
format always a chance for tennis elbow
as well so watch it make sure you see a
doctor if you start to get aches and
pains it feels very arthritic at first
but it's actually channes elbow yeah
and Zbornak is trying to use his elbow
to get some room on the kingside here
you know h4 oh wait that was right the
oh it doesn't but I every wanted to play
over here by Nakamura to give up the
rope to get the deep on because all of a
sudden the tables have turned and it's
clear that black has decide to be
preferred your space in the center it's
easier to play in a bullet oh we hung
him when we bought her tonight oh well
this is legit missed it yeah he did the
shockingly well did you see the when a
car ooh his primal screen because he
didn't hit so what's him we call it oh
oh no you see oh nice recheck was a
threat no he's got a treat please he's
probably gonna throw the challenge Ricky
Warwick only has 17 seconds so he won't
he won't throw in the towel the kornek
is known for the scramble he likes his
eggs scrambled and a-five win it in time
most the time writing up to and then
oh he just sacks decision you don't like
it no it takes too long to get over
there look he's not gonna win this game
he's got no time ridiculous a car was
gonna draw this game Oh take a 97 hurry
up
yes all the pawns the only chance is to
pre move it out ah he's gonna preman
drill he get the mate in time I made him
oh man I don't know I don't know yeah
he's got king of two and he's got two
may well that is amazing how quickly
bortnik can turn on the Jets and just
thruster thrust through that victory in
the pre move in the pre move lane like
he moves over the HOV Lane and it's like
the car headshake number 16 I think yeah
yeah maybe reading up on your Danny
Hikaru Wikipedia yeah you know it's the
got to know it right hiccup edia yep
trapped and a gypsy seven would have won
that row construct bishops have now
still does we find the bobble head is
back what look at this room p5 use the
light square control so if you get Queen
to g6 plate and ya bortnik has chances
especially if he drives the H pawn and
gets the two knights involved there will
be in a town man 9h for our k18 he wants
h3 though he probably could've even
played it there and Brooke oh my god two
games of of blunders for Hikaru
back-to-back looks like he's lost his
edge a little bit being up two sets I
guess we'll do that to you but he's got
to pull it together bring your king to
f5 just play like this and it Carson's
winning chances here because the end
game is favorable for white but he's
trying to if the Knights get traded won
a pair of knights and black could take
over the light squares that's what for
days hoping for and boarding is not
playing fast enough he needs to play
more quickly start trading pawns so that
way you can hold the draw another 15
seconds and he's again he's gonna put a
car in a position to win this game speed
up you're right man just play g4 ready
non-branded sippy-cup
take on d8 take on h3 play at 4 ok not
to draw though if he gets the pawns off
now take Jake oh good night into f5
going down a pawn though and it should
be a draw probably in classical chess
but yeah but OTB is is not to be had
bullet you're right hey Caro he might
milk out the victory yeah he's got this
bad decision just in a loss king upon
anything no right there's no time
there's no time
wait what how did both sides Queen I
turn away for a second look at the chat
thinking Carter lost the tempo there
somewhere but I'm gonna be honest I
blacked out over the last like 17 moves
[Laughter]
live Tara says would love it boarding it
in the fog the last game what a card
just quit like he's about to win the
match yeah just like I play this okay
right now this is the makings of a
potential attack for wipe the blackfish
one 8f
camera confirms we miscalculated the paw
netting should have been a draw so we
did yep I did this year with ham or
whatever the microphone and he does it
yeah poor dick straw look at the dark
squares here and that goes to e4 to d6
yep love it love it highlight it you
talk it I'll highlight it baby all night
oh he's breaking the pawn chain yeah yes
from me making up though getting on that
square he wants to go to just to d4 they
ain't gonna run to d4 one set and one
movie would be great for Marty nice move
g5 though I think rookie 5 d4 take on we
can't take on c5 you have the d4 the
deep hole is running yep any more picks
up h6 that's why I like g5 because it's
separated the pawn chain and prevented
boarding from defending them yeah but I
think though the pawn is too advanced so
Brooke 8 King G we remember cage 5 yeah
now you got to be careful of your Recaro
if this King gets in front hey Carl
could get mated yep so Amaro prevents
that by holding the e-file oh nice move
there so Oh is he gonna he's all-in oh
there was no rook b8 man you always
scared that but wait was there and then
king g7 in the F pod oh you're and then
G oh my gosh you got a point
yeah no idea but probably it doesn't
work cuz when am I ever right about
calculation I mean but seriously that
looks super risky hey Carl just winning
and up on the clock bortnik pissed he
played the move Queen a7 the reason he
shakes his head there everybody is
that's a no-no in Queen endings a
crossfire check black was able to block
the check and give a check at the same
time hammer goes Danny's right about
this count Danny you are so much better
when in bullet chest I know what's
happening
keep talking right now yeah you're just
so good
you're so hot soul gosh it's so hot
right now well here Zbornak opting for
the solid set we saw Federico once I do
this a lot yesterday right he played
this sort of excuse me we takes f6 is
that a blunder had to be there's no way
you're happy about this the shrubs
falling apart put a nine on a five and
talk about how you're happy to see me
I'm gonna make the Queen dance on g7
here he comes here he comes
the girl right there there you go oh
look at Zbornak shaking his head to that
g4 square but it's not gonna matter the
Queen's not dancing David if she's
dancing she's dancing with another man
so we're slow dipp'd it so dancing in a
burning room right now this relationship
business before it freaks
oh we're with you dude he's good man
he's good hey Karl looks like he's about
to fall asleep on this match he goes I
think the bond cloud might come out
maybe we tell her Carlo he's not allowed
to win the match unless he wins with the
bond cloud in the last game so the set
will continue until he wins with the
bond cloud oh no now he's gonna win this
game too because Zbornak went for a
sacrificial line down upon oh yeah the
king is safe it's about to Castle the
pain on d4 is annoying it's just extra
material for hey Karan Nakamura well
regardless of the result everybody we
will have Hikaru Nakamura for a
post-match interview olexander bortnik
some some language barrier issues there
and unfortunately also some chef's
barrier issues right now between him and
Hikaru as acara wins again before I can
even complete my sandwich here but yes
so stick around Hikaru Nakamura will
give us his thoughts on the event and
and where he goes from here and his in
his bullet career there's nowhere to go
but down it feels like yeah I mean he
reached 3,300 that'd be pretty sweet at
taking over the dark scores you take
take rookie seven there's 90 to be seven
the nine seasickness hang even if
there's Knight takes d4 Intermezzo so it
was a complicated position complicated
line here tonight see see there he goes
a four to c5 or b6 here he's come to c5
right away this is nice you can't move
here double quickly all this basics
under the pawn
Oh you Sheriff well he took one of them
didn't get the other palm but that
allowed the knight to come in to d3 so
you might have been right
I think the a6 ball was better when in
place before I think challenging the c4
made have been the better play there
while the Brooks were disconnected but
he missed it
just the a pawn is weaker than the beat
pong cuz the 92 so strong okay to bring
rotation or rotate you yeah very nice
yeah now you can even just bring your
king over King up one can you one
simplification killed the board Nick
that's where he's going here could put a
bishop on d1 to guard b3 or get the
rooks off the board this way
compensation has been aborting act here
and it's just not gonna happen for him
rook d3 okay Brooke might even get
trapped in there Roxy one trap the rook
and Bishop b2 c2 over c7 then Bishop see
to ensure whoa oh he just did he blunder
I guess he did he did but actually you
get some compensation out of this
put your Bishop on e4 bring your rook to
the rook C 194 rook takes Bishop takes
finding some cop yeah but it's not
enough how many pawns is wet out card
was gonna simplify it in again look at
the clock
yeah I'd even look at the clock was
looking at the board oh man oh man this
is this is a struggle he's so fast it's
just it's just too real to real
so this h6 technique is not working out
for Zbornak but it keeps going back to
it because he's gaining spaces and quick
moves but what's been happening is black
has been able to Harry the threats and
then go after the palm later in the game
so look at this it's like a French with
your pawn h6 and this is this is match
game right now this is game set match
point right it was bad you know watch
more tennis I I knew that but we don't
have a nevermind we're gonna figure out
our terminology for future tennis slash
chance last chance matches but it is it
is game set match point right now and
he's up 14 seconds in the clock he's up
on the board
don't go anywhere everybody Hikaru
Nakamura will be with us in the
interview here in just a few moments I'm
just completely impressed proud
flabbergasted OMGs are snaps I'm all I'm
all I knew where you're going with that
Dani I'm proud of this you have six what
down for tactics here for dick maybe
gets this last game Oh No hey Carlo
shakes his head and says dude I love you
it's time to go back it's time to go
back to the lab where we gonna do
tomorrow try to beat hit car Nakamura
bullet I just feel bad for portly he's
bright red and just frustrated it's over
yeah well I mean okay like he's a
brilliant he's a brilliant kid obviously
a monster bullet but this is this is a
match that that no man can can stand at
this point and Hikaru Nakamura indeed
has won the first ever bullet Chess
Championship don't go anywhere we're
gonna be right back I've just been
informed that we will actually both
players in her interview with a little
bit of help from a face that you'll
recognize in terms of translation we're
gonna take our last and final break of
the day but I'm still watching all 74
hundred and sixty-two of you with my
evil dark web goggles sit right there
we'll be we'll be right back and we are
now rejoined by everybody here we have
the winner of the day grandmaster Makar
Nakamura along with the the man who was
right there with him all week and then
fell here in the finals Alexander
bortnikov you for being here with us in
this in this post event interview so the
first two car congratulations to you and
let me ask that we previewed the format
yesterday and got your got your general
thoughts on an end now having played in
our kind of unofficially dubbed tennis
format what were your thoughts on it did
you did you like the fact that drawers
didn't count toward the total score if
you would please I'm gonna ask this
player to Alexander as well what are
your general feelings now having played
in the in the channeis that breaking
down by game set and match format yes
yes please okay so I mean I guess first
of all I think if there is a mismatch it
definitely is gonna favor the lower
rated player without a doubt so I think
there's a bit of a mismatch of players
arm of the same caliber there's gonna be
quite a big difference for me it didn't
really make a big it didn't matter but I
think for example if I play dolly Reza
in this format or in the 30-minute
format I think it would have been
extremely tight and there would have
been some luck depending on what the
score
Scott - because I think about it like
ali reza or magnus you have a lot of
matches where it's like five four or
five five that it's really really tight
and the match hinges on one or two games
so i don't know if that determines the
better quality necessarily as opposed to
who plays better under the pressure now
you could say about another way of
looking at it but but for me at least
this time around to make a big
difference so i'm just happy to one okay
they al exam do you mind relaying that
that question for for olexander what he
thought of the format did he enjoy it
and what his general thoughts on on this
new new way of grouping games together
and she has an the drawers didn't count
did he like that part
alexandria vision pyramid love us done
coached wash moon sleep about the
Fermata paducah growls a palpable photo
ID obtained easiest said yes commodity
she tired such emotion the period of
personal courage stuff in our center
basis Yamini awesome of still can boost
regret you carry easily have but strive
was past chorus to national she what
absolutely yes enough do much resin
storage sequent another issue blues
which install button
Trina Padilla dodging serious appearing
well Alexander is saying that he had no
idea about the format actually he
actually confuse it with the semi-finals
rules and he just found out just before
the final about this set and points but
he's saying that he car was so strong
too fast and when he is trying to play
as fast as he car okie blunders and when
he is trying to think he is below I mean
on time very fast so there is a lot of
time to work and of course he got tired
a bit more because he needed to
all the qualifiers and qualifications so
basically that's what he said amazing
Thank You Alexandra and thank you
olexander um so here karma then on that
on that note we've you've been referred
to several times today is as too strong
too fast the the anti famous phrase
known from Magnus Carlsen video with his
train or too weak too slow so let me ask
you would Magnus Carlsen have a chance
against you in this format I think in
this format I think it's gonna be close
no matter what I mean or making a big
deal out of what out of what I wrote
yesterday in the chat but I do think
that in general the two people who have
a chance against me in any format
regardless are gonna be Magnus and ali
reza fruit i think both of them regards
are gonna have a chance I think actually
if we play a long match it's gonna come
down to a bit of luck and who wins at
critical moments whether it's straight
up points or whether it's in this tennis
format so I don't think I mean I would
say that I think I'm the favorite but I
don't think it's clear at all that I'm I
would be either of them Alexandra would
you mind asking olexander who he would
pick in a match of 100 between Dakar
Nakamura Magnus Carlsen Alexandra you
approach timing comes the mrs. Graff his
girl's name is Makar Ono past chorus
Tiffany's Eric booth bustier but by
silly prepositional manipulate and we
have a pasta in Chicago
okay well the answer of Alexander he he
does play in leach has some comments and
he did play against Carson but in his
point of view he's saying that Hikaru is
faster in terms of well chess wise
approximately same level so his bed
would be on he karo in the match between
Hikaru and Carson okay Robert Wow
yeah there's I mean
car you seem to get ahead well out on
the clock which is typical for you but
did you have any specific strategy to
stay a couple seconds ahead of Alexander
knowing that in the past couple of
matches he did extremely well when it
came down to the wire on the clock
yeah I mean I think there's one there's
one big difference between me and like
like Maxine for example which is because
I did watch the match out straight
between Nolan's matter and Maxim very
closely on which is that I think that in
general Alexander's just a good as pre
moving as I am but I'm much better at
the anticipation of his premiums than
Maxime it's like when Maxine was was up
to ten seconds and match it seemed like
Alexander was able to make all these pre
moves gain the time and Maxine was not
anticipating so he kept getting back a
time advantage I think that was a big
difference is that unlike Maxime I was
very much a believe the pre moves and
sort of see where they're coming from
simply because I know I'm so used to
doing it as well I think that was the
big difference is that when I got up on
time I was still able to keep the time
advantage because of that so that I
think was the big difference shout-out
to chess come France our our French
affiliate who just raided us with that
party of 191 Alexander I have a question
for for olexander that we previewed this
match and showed some of the the
infamous swindles I don't know how else
to put it where Alexander just seems to
anticipate as a Carter's alluded to very
well pre moving opportunities ways to
trick his opponent ways to take
advantage of their pre moves there was a
very famous stalemate yesterday against
Sasha Gray shook and I'm wondering if
you could ask him does he feel like that
he has a good sense for that of when his
opponent is free moving and how he takes
advantage of that and whether he thinks
that's a skill that can be learned in
practice if you play a lot of bullet
well approach shoot
Priya's khazzani that's true Hoda Amin
alia
wash in spirit do go Dali at we're done
but was nicking baski not school car
which it is devoted to God when you're a
tree at the severe neck of bullets your
chin vajna
what hikaru what meters just to
kamikatsu that arise it's every enemy
who was watching
[Music]
well Alexander totally agrees that it's
very important to anticipate and to pre
move right sometimes and well in this
particular match he was playing very
cautiously and didn't really remove a
lot of moves and he agrees that well the
strongest bullet players do anticipate
moves very well and but yeah this in
this particular match he didn't really
rely on this anticipation and remove
very much got it
well we know that Hikaru has an amazing
streaming channel and if some of the
nearly 7,000 of you didn't know that and
go to twitch.tv /gm Hikaru right now we
also have our guest here Alexandra
Cassini a former women's world champion
competitor and the upcoming women's
speeches championship Thank You
Alexandra and you have a twitch channel
twitch.tv slash chess Queen but the the
natural next question is now that
Alexander got a fancy new webcam that we
made him buy for this match is he gonna
start streaming will you ask him that
tell him tell him we're growing our
audience in Russian and we can help him
get started ready shoot
[Music]
well Alexander saying that he actually
did start his channel about a year ago
and he was trying to do some stream so
but so I mean he has some intentions to
continue and about the webcam actually
it was very difficult task for him
because it's Sunday and apparently every
shop was closed in he is right now so he
spent a lot of time and finally found a
friend who had the webcam who lent it to
him so yeah that was very quite hard for
him to solve the technical issues as
usual and he does hope to start
streaming but for that he hopes to
improve his English and then he will do
it imagine it well thank you for that
that was and we really we really do
appreciate him securing the webcam at
the
the last moment but um I don't really
have any other questions I just I do do
it question hey Cara do you remember the
game the last game you played against
oleksandr before this match no I mean
I've heard about it's obvious I'm aware
I was thinking that in general if you're
gonna do that yes thank you for thank I
had to save the best for last
in the set format you can't actually try
that because if you try it it doesn't
work it's like you you throw a game and
you guys are toast like it's one game
you can do but I was singing in like an
overall match you can actually try stuff
like that a bit more because the game in
in and overall when is its game when it
won every game counts if it doesn't work
but it works like one out of two even or
one out of three it might be worthwhile
to to tilt your opponent whereas right a
set format you can't really try because
if it doesn't work
I mean psychologically you're just
crushed so it's it's interesting now I
think about but no I didn't remember the
game but I mean he's tried it I think
ali reza has done it plenty of people
have done it like I knew have a
follow-up question here about moves like
that maybe not in the opening so much
but I remember watching Olly raise a
play and I remember it was against you
or in the qualifiers but he like would
take a pawn that wasn't a free pawn like
he just gets Bishop captured but because
there's mutual time trouble like how do
you go about when to take a pawn or to
put your rook on pre but attack the
other person's rook like how do you time
those decisions I mean I don't really do
that I did it one time very famously
against Eric a couple Eric Hansen a
couple of years ago and everyone I think
it's seen the clip of that on the work
but I was gonna say I don't really use
that trick that often I think the two
people who are extremely good at that
our firuzan and Dania they both they
both like use that trick all the time
against me even even in blitz like we
get that thumbs ikenson and all the
rezident if this takes up two against me
yes yes that was what I was thinking
about work it didn't work but that's a
trick and a skill that I don't really
possess so I can't comment in terms of
like how to do it but like if you want
to know a gasps Kali wrestler
those guys are the guys who use that
trick - max what I was gonna ask about
that is what do you think the biggest
advantage of those tricks are obviously
it's only one game even if it works but
but are you kind of doing it because if
it does work then it's really kind of
like you know now it's pissed you off
right now it's like it is it more about
the psychological potential to put your
opponent on tilt than it is the fact
that it may actually work and maybe
after Hikaru answers maybe you could ask
olexander why he does it is he trying to
put his opponents on tilt I think you're
gone let's say it's like seven seconds
against five seconds for example I will
fly up say that I'm not faster than ali
reza word yeah so when they do that and
then they can make like three moves very
quickly it's sort of it's a block but if
it works then and you're anticipating
then at the end of the game assuming it
goes wrong for you you are actually
slightly on tilt so it's sort of an odd
thing and I think like I said I don't
really do it and I don't know how to do
it but um but I think definitely it can
tell your phone for sure Alexandre new
approach probity chicken's neck okay
naruse cannot vanish a stone can receive
a chest of attack
Shruti tea party apologetic ye keep Rio
my back sheer smooth soft I keep prayin
off new chrome interest approached my
grits ESP guru let me tell ya disability
route appear Emilio three Amish Nimoy
chef Martin decision stood second liquid
material tips of de Graaff permanent
eating English classical movie as
material
commentary materials to be Resnick
rotten concert illuminated which asked
to examine be noted the soonest Reza
crowd which the result the nagas praya
barat
nationals leads of tuna crippled chess
you can
Cornish Rex no she was careless the
caboose look at that
mr. graduation party given lost upon yet
but Sharon has of short volodenka trip
decision
Yahoo the crews loyal stuff so yeah
mister soonish a special position you
initially decide stop sub changeup and
risky we are done mr. Bouie shakuhachi
we gram-positive cocci specious
administered promotion Blanche is senior
pages Nevada yes
newspapers do you talk to the guests
okay well about this story was hit karo
actually Alexander said that by the time
he played Bishop h6 they already played
like 90 games and he was losing
approximately one two three I mean and
everything so he was very tired and
disappointed he decided to use this
three just you know just out without
[Music]
texted something to him
and while he was translating Alexander
he tried to translate what he karo to
exit
he can already banned Alexander him to
play like a gentleman way was no such
dirty tricks and but since since it took
time for Alexander to translate would he
car actually wrote he was banned for one
and a half years but now everything is
it's fine and well Alexander is saying
that he doesn't use this tricks very
often usually when he does play
something like this it's either when
he's very tired or and disappointed and
lost already like previously ten games
in a row or it's on the very last second
Sam that's that's a part of bullet chess
lives make sense so a car you forgive
him for the trick then people can
definitely do it
I mean without people can do it I mean
if some it's the most basic and most
annoying trick to have to deal with it
but I play feeling hetero systems that
every so often someone will try it
Ali rez has done it many times but you
know it's it is part of the game and I
will say I will say that during this
match day I was actually you will see I
was not making my third and fourth
feelings immediately I was sort of
waiting to make sure he didn't do this
we got towards the third set it was a
real possibility that he would well to
answer the questions there's been some
questions about this whole discussion
about the trick so I promise I'm never
playing it for any of the reason that
the trick everybody is that when you're
anticipating your opponent to have
already pre moved this next move a six
you would play a bit or Knight f6 right
so you're anticipating that your
opponent has pre moves something and
there's a very good chance in bullet
that they do they could premium a6 c6 d
6 that's the car was saying right and so
the point is Bishop h6 takes advantage
of that pre move and then wins on the
spot with the move Bishop takes g7 where
you're not only winning a piece but
likely the rook that follows which is
why the fee and keto is is typically one
of the most devastating ways to do this
sort of pre move trick so Bell sub I saw
your comments a few minutes ago was just
waiting and for anybody who didn't know
now you know and if you didn't know how
great bullet chess was now you know that
as well thank you everybody that has
been here this has been amazing honestly
so much I don't know that we've had this
much fun in a week on chess calm in a
very long time so I hae karo
congratulations again Alexander also
congratulations to you for having an
amazing week honestly of everybody you
played you're the only person who can
say you played in every event the first
ever bullet chess championship starting
from Wednesday through Sunday so thank
you for doing that
congratulations Alexandra lets you relay
my congratulations hopefully and then
we'll well I will say goodbye and I
please news to play any emotions
collecting the weigh-ins to make rocket
receiver gap was Christina Vasya worship
Tony Rock bringing the Premio Chester
doc stone insurance corrosion corrosion
ideally you should become well thank you
thank you to both of our players again
congratulations let's bring up our
bracket one last time and remind
everybody of how we got here is we say
goodbye to our to our players as well as
our guest translator thank you so much
Alexandre and there you have it
Hikaru Nakamura wins the bullet chess
championship by a score of three to nil
in our set format well this has been
this has been such a wild ride we still
have almost 6,000 people with us been
amazing thank you to everybody that is
still here as well as all of our mods
all of our subscribers we had a lot of
people selling there in the last few
moments and we just didn't have a chance
to say their names on screen so thank
you for that Robert I got nothing left
in me man
I got a Sunday at home right now I'm
thinking a little bit of grilling a
little bit of barbecue I don't know the
dog could get but I'm gonna stop by the
grocery store on the way home some
grilling and chilling for you yeah grill
chill I'm thinking about what my haircut
I can't wait for it it's been a long
time coming you would be both I grew out
the Grizzly Adams look competition here
but it's time right you know they say in
a stars board maybe it's time that the
old ways died maybe it's time to let all
these dead ends die and get so you can
avoid split ends by using a very
nutrient-rich shampoo one that hydrates
your hair and doesn't leave it dry and
frizzled you know I got that net those
natural curls baby that's right you got
that you got you got Garnier Fructis
coming out of your hair naturally right
well today was done purposely usually
it's not I just you know let it just I
let it flow let it flow I don't hold it
back anymore so I feel like I'm ready to
do a whole nother show I know so it's
fun the car oh thank you bored Nick
thank you everybody really really
appreciate you being here all of our
moderators everybody that makes this
possible there's so many people behind
the scenes
Simon Nick everybody who's working so
hard shout out to Studio C let's get a
shot one more time we've actually got a
guest here who's been who's been spying
over the shoulder of my man R and
learning what he can if we can if we can
get the studio C on camera not sure if
we can there you go there you go what's
up guys just working so hard over there
so cute hit that light if that light do
your thing you do you see Dr Pepper hit
the follow extension get it give them a
follow our guide Lord from our in Hawaii
thank you to everybody that's here we're
gonna we're gonna send things off
whoever we're raiding and host and I
don't know I just work here and do what
they tell me to do lawrence trent verse
Greg Johar tea time that's right oh my
gosh don't go anywhere because that's an
epic matchup epic matchup one that well
I'm not even gonna predict a winner
Robert enjoy your Sunday afternoon peace
love and happiness to all of you yes
until until next time peace out
everybody see ya
[Music]